i did want to ask about the ending a
little bit and first off carrie what was
your
very first reaction to getting the end
of the script and discovering her fate
yeah i think my first reaction was sort
of the audience reaction of like oh
no that's so not what you want to happen
um
you know so you it and then and you know
the audience feels that too
and i think um but i'm just so proud of
emerald for sticking to her guns and
um i think you know a lot of people may
have been persuaded
um to to change that ending to something
that ultimately just wouldn't have felt
real um we know the truth around um
those kind of scenarios and they they
don't go generally
um in the favor of the woman when it
comes to physical
you know hand-to-hand combat um and the
the fairy tale version the fantasy
version of this would have been that
you know um castle walks away um
you know in a sort of uh triumphant
strut uh and leaves everyone um on the
floor but it's it's just not
it's not the truth and i think em felt
very very strongly that it's important
to tell the truth about
um things like this so um i'm really
proud of
emerald for being so clear on that and i
do think
you know it's part of the reason why you
can't forget about the film
uh when you walk away it's not a film
that you can that you can just sort of
put down to being a fun experience it
stays with you um in part because it
doesn't give you
you know the easy way and um so and then
that's what continues the conversation
it was very much my read on it as well
um just to get a little bit into
cassie's headspace throughout that big
third act
were you playing it as though she kind
of knew she was on a mission
that could end this way or was it little
a little bit more of a of an ambiguous
mind frame where
the things she had planned might not
have been needed
yeah i think it was the latter more than
i think that
i never imagined it wasn't a suicide
mission but she had become
cavalier with her life so it wasn't the
she wasn't going
knowing that she wasn't coming back she
put things in place in case that
happened she knew there was a
probability a possibility of that
happening
um but there was a the will to live
was still there um but yeah i think
she's just
by that point so much had happened and
there was so much anger that i think
she sort of doesn't she doesn't
overthink it